on craque et on leur dit par exemple
rapide daguestan il répondra daguestan
comme ça ils comprennent bien afin qu'il
soit pas battu l école à l'école on doit
se battre
[Musique]
je m'appelle oumar no mago madoff j'ai
23 ans je représente le daguestan mon
record professionnel est de 9,09 kombat
9 victoires aucune défaite
dieu soit loué on voyage dans différents
pays
et quand nous disons que nous venons de
russie les gens nous disent vous ne
ressemblez pas à des russes ça peut être
un peu différent parce que les russes
ont la peau plus claire et donc pour
expliquer nous leur disons par exemple
rabin daguestan et ils répondent
adacore daguestan comme ça ils
comprennent des pays arabes ou en europe
quand vous dites rats bible les gens
comprennent que vous venez du sud de la
russie
peut-être qu'ils ont vu une vidéo sur le
bayer ce temps ou quoi que ce soit et
ils comprennent
si vous parcourez le daghestan pas les
grandes villes mais les villages reculés
vous y verrez des enfants qui portent
des t-shirts avec le nom rabin nous
remet à gober dof les achète ça au
marché noir parce que reebok ne les
fabrique pas ils sont fabriqués ailleurs
mais ça les intéresse vraiment je crois
que le succès de rabin a eu un énorme
impact sur tout le monde
de plus en plus d'enfants font du sport
m
[Musique]
les gens attendent de moi que je
combatte aussi bien que lui je sois
aussi fort que je sois aussi fort
grappling que je sois rond durant
lorsque je regarde les combats j'entends
toujours les commentateurs précisé c'est
l'école d'abdou manable nous mark madoff
ses étudiants ont une bonne endurance et
moi je me sens responsable je dois me
montrer digne
je dois suivre les traces des autres
élèves dabdoub la nappe qui ont déjà
fait preuve d'un haut niveau au combat
j'observe tout le temps mon frère aîné
je vois comment ils se comportent et
c'est suffisant pour moi on n'a pas
besoin de parler et c'est simple vous ne
devez jamais être désagréable même si
vous êtes très fatigué vous devez être
poli quand vous refusez mais cela ne
m'arrive presque jamais
[Musique]
cette génération d'athlètes qui obtient
de bons résultats
ils ont regardé leurs prédécesseurs ils
ont vu combattre des champions
olympiques de la génération précédente
et il voit aussi qu'ils vivent bien
tout le monde veut participer à des
compétitions chez nous tout commence à
l'école primaire les enfants veulent
gagner à voir la première place
peut-être que c'est quelque chose de
génétique
notre entraînement commence presque tous
les jours avec un match de rugby
basket-ball joue 20 25 minutes et puis
une fois échauffés nous procédons à
l'entraînement principal et c'est
également bon pour améliorer son
endurance qui courent dans tous les sens
on lutte
on doit penser à qui passer et comment
changer de position c'est excellent pour
s'échauffer
elle raconte la première mi temps est
terminé on joue d'habitude deux mi-temps
de 12 15 minutes chacune
nous menions 3-0 voilà c'est le rugby
daguestanais
pour l'instant on perd on a parié le
dîner l'équipe perdante pays pour le
dîner et si on perd j'ai promis que je
paierais moi même il va falloir réserver
une table je crois
[Applaudissements]
est ce que tu fais tu as presque cassée
dubaï rares
[Applaudissements]
alors je serai direct on a perdu c'est à
tourner aucun problème dit mois
seulement dans quel restaurant
désolé on verra ce 6 0
je suis invité ici après tout ce serait
impoli de battre l'équipe locale je dois
montrer du respect et j'ai fait preuve
de respect envers mes frères
daguestanais aujourd'hui nous avons
perdu
beaucoup de boxeurs de combattants de
champion olympique
moi aussi je me demande parfois pourquoi
les dagestan et représente la russie
mais il y en a aussi qui combattent pour
le bahreïn pour le royaume uni et pour
d'autres pays
il arrive même que plusieurs dagestan et
participe à la même compétition
internationale de mma et se rencontrent
en finale
j'y réfléchissais surprenant on va faire
ça devant la caméra oumar allez je vais
vous montrer maintenant attendez et tu
ne cédera pas c'est ça je te connais
bien bien jouer et à gagner
je les faits devant la caméra c'est la
première fois de sa vie
oui c'est la première fois que je gagne
2,2 points violent et l'ont filmée ou
bah oui bien sûr en tout cas à l'école
vous êtes obligé de vous battre
c'est comme ça que ça marche soit vous
demander à tout le monde de vous laisser
tranquille et admettez qu'ils sont plus
forts
soit vous vous battez pour être respecté
alors tout le monde se bat je ne crois
pas qu'il y ait quelqu'un ici qui ne se
soit pas battu à l'école
as tu as vu un homard travaille tout le
temps
peu importe qu'il ait un combat qui
approchent ou non nous avons des
entraînements réguliers le matin et le
soir
oumar bosse dur il est jeune peut
importe combien de temps il lui reste
trois ou quatre jours quel que soit son
adversaire il peut s'y préparer
je connais oumar depuis l'enfance nous
sommes une famille je le connais depuis
tout petit la première fois qu'il est
venu chez nous à la salle il avait
quatre ou cinq ans je crois c'était un
tout petit garçon qui courait là avec
nous et pas à pas il est devenu un
excellent combattant
c'est déjà un sparring partner pour moi
vous savez les aînés serve d'exemple aux
jeunes nous nous entraînons ensemble par
exemple
et si quelqu'un obtient de bons
résultats il encourage deux ou trois
autres athlètes au minimum il les pousse
à s'améliorer au fil du temps ces trois
combattants inspire les autres y compris
les proches et de cette manière ils
deviennent de plus en plus nombreux et
voilà qu'un jour ils sont déjà 30 et
avec le temps ces gens vont en
encourager d'autres
voilà comment ça marche
j'ai fini ma préparation principal pour
le combat les sparrings l'ouest ning le
grappling la course
les exercices matinaux c'est fini il
faut maintenant éviter les traumatismes
et ce qui est le plus important faire le
bon poids je suis un régime
le matin et le soir je dois boire
beaucoup d'eau on transpire énormément
ça va oui à 61 2 500 g de marge de
tolérance
on va voir ça normal n'est ce pas oui
61,9 kg
bah
d'abord je mange des fruits et après je
peux manger plus de glucides une
solution de réhydratation et voilà je
suis prêt cinq ou six kilos ce sera
suffisant pour moi je pense à peu près
le même poids que j'avais une semaine
avant le combat serait optimal tu vas tu
manges et aujourd'hui de la soupe au
poulet avec du sel puis du riz et le
soir des pâtes
il faut beaucoup de glucides et pas trop
de viande car c'est trop lourd
mon poids doit être bon 79
c'est là que c'est le meilleur
j'ai perdu environ 10 kilos oui à peu
près 10 kilos avant le combat mon poids
sera de 70 kg au minimum je vais prendre
du poids je crois encore 7 kg je dois
récupérer avant le combat il faut donc
que je mange bien et après le combat je
pourrai manger tout ce que je veux des
fritures des sucreries tout
[Musique]